Europe's open borders are closing
Germany joins a growing list of EU
countries to at least partially shut out
their neighbours authorities here
deciding to close boundaries with
Switzerland and Austria that's according
to German media reports added
restrictions are also being imposed on
the French German boundary those
measures are expected to begin on Monday
in Germany itself authorities have not
yet imposed the kind of strict
nationwide measures we're seeing in
other European countries but authorities
are urging people to take precautions to
slow the spread of the coronavirus shops
have been busy as people stock up on
essentials and that's leading to
shortages of some items toilet paper for
example non perishable foods and
vegetables many German states have
decided to shut down schools and tourist
attractions joining me now is DW
correspondent William no igloo Croft
he's reporting for us in Berlin William
Germany now the latest country in Europe
to shut at least some borders what more
do we know at this hour about that
closure yes this information came across
just within the last hour or so from
German media reporting that yes borders
to France Austria Switzerland will if
not be fully closed at least be heavily
restricted starting Monday morning
starting with a Monday morning commute
it should be noted that has been no
official government announcement or
decision yet that is also reported to be
coming later this evening what exactly
the details of these closures or
restrictions are going to be it does
seem that non-essential traffic is going
to be stopped at the border to these
three particular borders but commuters
and goods will still be able to pass
through the borders apparently according
to reports the idea is not only to stop
the spread of the virus but also to stop
the spread of or the the amount of
people who are coming across borders to
try to squirrel away stocking up on all
kinds of products people who live in the
border region so that seems to be the
goal of what of what these border
restrictions are going to be but again
an official announcement will be coming
later this evening according to German
media reports William at least 10 other
countries
the EU or the Schengen area have closed
borders at well as well what does this
mean now for the EU which really prides
itself on freedom of movement yes
Germany of course has bordered a
neighboring countries beyond just these
three countries listed there have not
been announcements about those countries
this Czech Republic the Netherlands
Denmark Poland but these countries
themselves have also imposed their own
border restrictions already as have many
other you countries as we've just said
this is really the underpinning of the
EU of the idea of free movement and open
borders of goods and people this is what
the EU is all about and this is why
Germany has been really hesitant the
last in a couple of weeks to go along
with his border closure idea it's a
rather controversial idea of course
Germany has a long history it was a
divided country itself between East and
West during the Cold War where a well
ran through the country dividing the
border and keeping the border closed of
course the Iron Curtain between the
Soviet and the capitalist West and of
course in 2015 who can forget that
Angela Merkel is famous for keeping the
borders open during a migration crisis
and now she may be known as the
transferor who closed the borders at
least in part for this virus William
briefly if you can you're in Berlin some
restrictions have now taken effect what
does daily life look like where you want
I mean people are still out and about
but it's definitely rather quiet and the
full restrictions come in tomorrow with
schools clubs bars and the like public
life basically in general shutting down
and just to give you an idea of the
scale of what we're facing here in
Berlin 150,000 schoolchildren are
estimated to not have childcare once
those schools closed and only emergency
parents who have emergency jobs
essential jobs will be able to have that
emergency care for them and the rest of
the kids I still have to wait and see
what will happen with them William no
igloo kroff reporting for us in Berlin
thank you very much we want to bring in
DW correspond at Lisa Lewis she is in
Paris and Marcus bunich is reporting in
Madrid for us if we have
those two markets I want to ask you 47
million people in Spain there order to
stay inside now how do things look where
you are
well it seems that it works at least
here in Madrid this is maybe because
Madrid is four days now the hot spot in
Spain all over the country we have 2,000
more infections within 24 hours so
people here are taking it seriously
there are only few people in the streets
and what I've seen especially some
remaining tourists Lisa let's go to you
now strict lockdown measures in France
as well how are people responding in
Paris well I've been talking to some
people who told me that they understood
the measures that they understood that
the cases of newly contaminated people
had gone up but when you walk through
the streets here in Paris there are not
deserted the local food shop for example
a lots of people there they were not
keeping any distance and also their
pictures of packed farmers market here
in Paris it looks like not everybody is
taking this seriously well clearly this
sort of thing is not easy to enforce
Marcus in Spain our authorities trying
to make sure that people follow this
lockdown
while people firstly were informed about
the possible punishments up to 30,000
euros if you are not respecting the
lockdown rules people can walk out when
they have to buy food when they have to
go out with the dog when they have to
care for some other people for example
but the rest of the people have to stay
at home and police is controlling it and
the government is focusing concentrating
the powers on every policy the police
unit here even in the regions so they
have to they are standing under the
government decisions and rules and we
saw they're even using drones to make
announcements to two people they're
outside Lisa now Frances Prime Minister
is called kovat 19 the quote biggest
health crisis in the century and yet
France holding local elections today
tell me about that why do they go ahead
with this election yes absolutely there
was a lot of pressure on the government
to carry them out actually that your
position was saying especially the
center-right party was saying that you
need to have these elections but there
has been a lot of criticism the
government said we were put in place
specific measures certain distances
between people voters at the polling
stations bars been walking around and at
the polling stations I went to there
were so many people that there was no
minimum distance to be kept and no one
was seemed to be using that disinfectant
that was put there for people who went
to vote and the local election worker
even told me that there were too many
people to disinfect the polling stations
in between that they didn't have time
for that so there is certain certainly a
lot of criticism that the government
might be facing if this these local
elections today increase the number of
contaminated people in the coming days
Lisa Lewis reporting forests in Paris
Marcus finish in Madrid thank you so
much to you both well as we heard the
Spanish government imposing severe
restrictions on public life the latest
country to do so ordering its forty
seven million citizens to essentially
stay home
restaurants and non-essential shops
there have been told to close streets as
we saw in the capital city deserted as
authorities declared national emergency
now Spain reported 1,500 new coronavirus
infections and 70 deaths in just one day
in fact the wife of Prime Minister Pedro
Sanchez and two government officials
have tested positive for Copa de 19:00
citizens in Europe and around the world
adapting to drastic changes to daily
life as new lock downs and restrictions
go into effect due to the corona virus
pandemic we won't take a look now at
some of the latest developments England
is planning self-isolation measures for
all people above the age of 70 for up to
four months Austria's Chancellor's of
Oschin courts says his government ban is
banning gatherings of more than five
people due to the Krone virus Iran's
death toll has now left by 113 in one
day to reach 724 and the Vatican says
all Easter services will take place
behind closed doors no worshippers and
attendants Pope Francis is holding
Sunday blessings via TV and the Internet
meanwhile the United States has
tightened its ban on visitors from
Europe president Donald Trump says it
will now include travelers from Britain
and Ireland who were exempted from the
initial ban a week ago Trump said he was
also considering travel restrictions
within the United States to areas hit
hardest by the viruses spread in
countries that are far away from
coronavirus hotspots the response from
authorities has ranged from tough to
non-existent and that's causing worries
that the pathogen could easily spread to
other parts of the world
as the corona virus pandemic councils
public gatherings and sparks lockdowns
around the world in Mexico crowded
scenes like this have raised more than a
few eyebrows tens of thousands of music
fans flocked to Mexico City's Viva
Latino festival at the weekend while
entrance staff carried out temperature
checks once inside you would barely
notice the difference but some fans were
angry that the organizers didn't cancel
the festival and attended because they'd
otherwise lose the price of the ticket
[Music]
know that some of the Bands we wanted to
see what canceled it seems disrespectful
to me that they didn't call the whole
event off and the fact that they put us
all at risk to tell you the truth
Mexican President Andres Manuel Lopez
Obrador shrugged off the risk of
infection at the weekend by holding
rallies with hundreds of supporters
sparking anger by kissing small children
elsewhere countries were clamping down
hard on their borders in Venezuela
people trying to reach Colombia were
left stranded after Bogota unilaterally
shut the border between the two nations
on Saturday with just a few hours notice
they should have warned us in time and
jointly agreed to close the borders so
as not to leave people in the streets
suffering in China authorities will send
International Arrivals to Beijing
straight to quarantine centers from
Monday infections brought in from
overseas now outnumber domestically
transmitted cases in the Philippines
police have sealed off the densely
populated capital Manila for a
month-long isolation though workers are
among those still allowed to enter and
leave like so many places around the
world
it's hoping drastic measures will slow
the viruses spread